foreign
on his computer and I saw that he was on
a dating site
yeah so I I catfished him
um no way did he fall for it oh he sure
did uh this is my favorite call ever
ever
[Music]
what in the world is going on this is
John with the Dr John deloney show
about your mental health
your emotional health what's going on
inside your house what's going inside
your heart and your mind and your head
ridiculous decisions you're making or
awful traumatic situations where you
find yourself whatever's going on in
your life my promise is I'll sit with
you and we'll figure it out
and we get
um countless I can't even thousands of
letters and emails and calls from all
over the planet and um we picked three
of them a show sometimes four sometimes
two and um
we reach out and we talk to real people
going through real stuff and so if you
want to be on the show shoot me an email
John deloney
j-o-h-n-d-e-l-o-n-y John deloney.com ask
ask or give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 leave a message and we
will hollaback girl at you I know holla
back girl and don't forget building a
non-anxious life still in pre-sale 20
bucks plus a whole bunch of other free
stuff and I think we just kicked back up
the autographed book when is this squad
Jenna
uh September 29th so only a few days
until this book is out that's right so
if you're if you're listening right now
the book comes out October 3rd and then
you're gonna have to pay whatever
wherever you get it but you lose all the
free cool stuff so pick it up right now
John deloney.com help a brother out all
right let's go to Atlanta home of the
most absurd
airport on planet Earth and talk to
Janelle what's up Janelle
hey Dr Zahn what's up how we doing
I have to remind myself to breathe I'm
so nervous
why why are you nervous I'm not great at
this you know
no you're awesome because I'm talking to
you and I'm like okay so it's like
millions of people probably listening
and I'm like oh my God I'm so nervous
Janelle I make up all those numbers
there's like 38 listeners
no you don't Max uh thank you thank you
so much for taking my call I really
appreciate it
all the time you've helped me with so
many things that have been going through
my head and
um I just want to say thank you and I'm
it's such an honor to get to talk to you
it's an honor to talk to you I'm really
grateful
um by the way while I've got you
please do whatever you can run for
public office do whatever you can fix
fix the airport what are we doing
oh I'm working on it I barely fly out of
here it's so ridiculous so by the time
you walk from the front gate to your
like gate you could have driven like all
the way to Nebraska anyway that's a
whole different conversation what is up
that's a whole different conversation
all right so like hit me with it what's
up
okay so um I'm gonna give you the back
story and then I'll ask that question
it'll all tie it in so bear with me
um so my husband and I we've been
married for 12 years we have two kids
um we got married pretty quickly it was
a pretty brief courtship so a lot of
things you would find out about your
partner before you get married we kind
of found out after we were already
married so it was kind of rough awesome
first couple of years you said that you
said that so eloquently
some of the things you find out
beforehand
um we found out after afterwards but the
way but I know what that probably means
and the way you said that so gently so
you're Delight okay keep going
it's been 12 years I I trust me I get it
right out so our main problem or my main
issue has been with um infidelity with
him mostly just internet issues and
texting and messaging and Facebook and
Instagram and so forth
um we've been to counseling quite a few
times three four times on and off
um he's also done individual counseling
a couple times and then things seem to
be pretty good for a while a few years
and then you know things happen and we
kind of end up back here
so um a few months ago he started acting
a little bit differently going out more
staying out a little bit longer I'm very
protective with his phone and accusing
me of cheating so um the light bulb kind
of went off and I was like okay
something's going on here so
um about a couple weeks ago I decided to
do some investigation
um so I went on his computer and I saw
that he was on a dating site
yeah so I I catfished him
um no way I sure yeah wait ah you did
did he fall for it oh he sure did uh
this is my favorite call ever ever yeah
hey can we call him right now and I'm
gonna pretend to be uh the husband of
the person please please
oh my gosh
um the thing was I knew it was probably
gonna happen because I know my husband
has been 12
so um um I created a fake profile I was
messaging him he was all for it oh
you're the worst and incredible all at
the same time
and lunch and um he's saying he was um
I'm divorced he did say
um so then I started I was going along
with it and I was going to you know meet
up with him yeah I was going to say make
a date with him man and record it and
we'll put it on the show
but but this is what happened I kept
looking and I came across to
um credit card receipts and I saw
um like two hotel receipts ah yeah not
funny anymore not funny anymore yeah
yeah and I kind of lie a lot yeah not
funny and I confronted him
um and he lied and said the first one
that was in our city he got it for a
friend
don't buy it and the other one that was
not in our city it was when he went out
of town to visit family and he said he
didn't want to stay at their house we
got a hotel I didn't buy that either
because he could just told me about it
he didn't he had me thinking he was
staying at his family's house and he
wasn't so I didn't buy any of that
um
so my husband has a tendency so the
counseling has been going through over
the years we've kind of figured out and
he'll admit that he has an issue with
attention and validation
and it's like when I'm not hold on hold
on Janelle Janelle Janelle Janelle
your husband cheats on you
period period
I have problems with validation I don't
get meet women in hotel rooms across the
country
yeah I like to
um
for my wife she told me nice things I
like for my wife to tell me she's proud
of me I like to fill in the blank
yeah you're right so so you can go to
counseling and learn all these neat
things and all that kind of stuff all of
that is a complete and utter wash
means nothing
if your husband is meeting other women
in hotel rooms across the United States
and then lying to you about it
here then you just period end of
discussion and here's what I think is is
unfortunate is that you
are so kind
and you are so there's something inside
of you that has told you that you don't
have equal value to him
that you have come up with some really
complicated narrative as to why this is
mostly your fault
and I'm telling you as a husband
that is not a true story that you tell
yourself
you're married to a Serial cheater
period yeah
yeah he's a guy who steps out on his
wife repeatedly and I've said on the
show I'll say it again I have a ton of
sympathy for
um
a business trip one night stand I have a
ton of sympathy for I met somebody am I
saying it's right I'm saying if somebody
sits down and goes dude this thing
happened
things happen or I was working on a
project with somebody for a year at work
and I I just fell head over heels I get
that this is
persistent and ongoing he's spitting in
his wife's face telling her she's stupid
you're so dumb you can't even find out
and when you're looking at receipts
he's like you're an idiot and you for
some reason Janelle believe yeah you're
probably right
even as you described you know listening
to you even as you described
the story about him going to see family
but staying in a hotel when I promise
you when he was there he was telling you
that I'm at Mama's house and she's
whatever
you the way you told that story if you
go back and listen you don't fully
you're not 100 that you're right
you're about 85 percent I'm telling you
you're 100 right
yeah
I know
and you probably don't want to be a
statistic you probably
have done whatever you could do for the
last decade to keep his family together
and you're married to someone who's
doing everything he can to unwind it
foreign yeah
you're right
you are right
and I've got like a like uh not in my
stomach talking to you right now
yeah you're right like I'm sick right
now
did you tell them that you uh
we're catfishing him did you tell him
does he even know that yet yeah yeah he
knows
friended him
then he apologized and you know acting
remorseful than saying
he wasn't gonna go and yada yada which
is a lie of course he was gonna be up of
course that's a lie
so the real question is less about him
the question is about you
is my marriage fixable
I think any marriage is fixable quite
honestly
but I you can't fix it alone
period
and quite honestly you've tried for for
10 years
you have to have a man that will tell
you the truth you have to have a man
that will tell you I'm sorry and you
have to have a man that will not end up
in a hotel room with a bunch of other
women he's not married to
are you perfect in this marriage no I
don't I don't even know and I'm telling
you no of course you're not no no right
and
has he weaponized any imperfection to
give him Liberty and license to do
whatever
he wants to yeah absolutely and you're
worth more than that and so are those
two little kids
let me say it this way I I'm gonna I'm
gonna take back my answer
ask me your question again
is my marriage fixable I will answer it
this way no
your marriage as it was is over
can you and your husband build something
completely new yes
have you heard my twin towers analogy
oh yeah okay same thing what y'all had
is over those Towers have fallen down
they are in rubble and in Ash and smoke
and there's dust everywhere
choice you have to make and I think
right now it's it's the initial choice
is you alone
are you gonna walk away from the towers
and let nature take him back
or are you gonna sit down with him and
say from this point forward we build
something new and here's my stipulations
here's what I need to move forward
and then you'll go get some
professionals to help you rebuild
something completely new
and that might mean new jobs that might
mean moving that might mean everything
is different because everything is
different
I mean you see what I'm saying
oh
yeah I do I my guess is you've had some
dark moments like where you're just
sitting in the shower when you're
finally by yourself
and You Weep so hard you can't you can't
catch your breath Fair
yeah that's fair that is so true I'm
just wondering why you know why me why
like this what what is it that I did no
you can't you can't your husband made
some bad choices over and over and over
and over and over again
and at this point if I'm being super
Frank
um
I'm worried about your health and safety
I'm worried about him bringing something
home from some woman that you don't know
about or multiple women that you don't
know about
right
and I I'm I'm as concerned for your
safety right this second as I am for
your marriage
I am too I said we have to definitely go
get we'll get tested because I don't
feel
I don't feel safe
Janelle sweetheart where does this come
from
who taught you that what you feel in
your guts is so wrong
because you've known he was cheating on
you for a long time
I knew and even the way you just said
just now like yeah I told him about
there's an uncertainty
instead of a proclamation at your front
door
you don't come in this home until you go
get tested period and you showed put the
you hand me the results
like who told you that that you're worth
so little that the what you feel and
what you think and what you need is of
of secondary importance
again
it didn't help that I see myself in my
parents relationship
where they're still together but I mean
my my dad practically cheered on my mom
the entire
45 years has been
married
so it's what your body knows right
yeah yeah
except the rules have changed in the
game has changed and Janelle my friend
Janelle's not gonna take this crap
anymore
here's why
because your two kids aren't going to
repeat this thing
right
they're gonna have a very clear picture
in their head of what either a strong
boundary and self-worth looks like
and a single mom who cannot be stopped
come hell or high water or
they're gonna have a ringside seat to a
couple fight and scratch and Claw their
way to something so remarkable and
strong and beautiful moving forward
but they're not going to learn
this is what marriage looks like
yeah you're right Fair
you're absolutely right now this is the
part of the story where like in the
movie When the Music swells and then
like the Montage scene happens this
isn't but that's not reality reality is
this do you work
not right now
um I got laid off a couple months ago
and I'm looking for for work now okay
this kind of self-proclamation has very
real economic consequences
right it sounds easy for me sitting in
Nashville Tennessee with a with a good
job to say you should just and that's
why I'm not gonna do that I'm not gonna
tell you to run out today
because there's a real question of where
do you go and how do you feed your kids
how do you eat right
right that's a very real thing and you
know as well as I do the court processes
are so jacked up it takes so freaking
long to get anything done
right
and so I would here's my my I mean I
just love talking to you you're a fun
you're funny you're like
you're such a great personality
thank you Dr John and I'm heartbroken in
my guts for you
and I I don't think I've told you
anything you didn't already know I'm
heartbroken in my guts because I sat
with women as they've walked what the
next two years of your life is going to
be and it's not going to be pleasant
and staying in this is not going to be
pleasant
you're right so the path you have to
choose is not one of ease and least
resistance and one of really hard you
have two incredibly difficult paths
ahead of you
and so I always want someone to choose
the difficult path that's going to lead
to Freedom
not lead to
repeating a cycle of abuse and you're
just gonna take it and this is just the
way things are over and over again
and dude I I would I'd love to talk to
your husband if he wants to call me
he won't he won't but I'd love to
he won't oh I know he won't he won't
here's here's I think your next steps
are number one I'd go get a counselor
today
in fact I'll hook you up with three
months of free better help if you don't
have a counselor in your area um stay on
the line here and we'll get you a code
and you can call somebody and be on the
phone or talking to them via Zoom within
the next 24 hours
thank you and here's what we're talking
about you need to get somebody and I
want you to be very specific when you
ask I need a game plan
to begin to identify my next steps I've
been married to somebody for a decade
who cheats on me and cheats on me and
cheats on me and now he's spending money
out of our family account now he's
increased up an uptick in lying he's now
traveling distances and I need to figure
out what my next steps are
and what they'll do is they'll help you
think through boundaries think through
do you have a mom or dad's house you can
go stay at for six months with the kids
do you have an attorney do you like some
of those hard questions you're gonna
have to face
also here's a testing site I mean
they're going to walk you through all
those those questions the second thing
is is I want you to get a couple of
girlfriends do you have two or three
women in your life that you trust a lot
I do
I want you to take them out to coffee
sometime this week and I want you to
tell them the truth because you have
never told them have you
no it's time
you need some real people in your corner
in your local community that knows the
truth about what you're experiencing and
dealing with
oh wow and this is part of the the
rising this is when Janelle
begins to come out of the water like on
our own two feet and this is my life
we're not doing this anymore
tell me why that scares you to death
because
I'm gonna have to come out of my
yes it's everything's okay shell
yeah yep you have created the most
beautiful it's all great and I'm
hilarious facade yeah you're so good
you're so good
yeah
that is
you have you I was going to say you have
no idea but you probably do because
we're a couple that everyone looks at oh
my God you guys are so perfect and it's
all great and you know
yeah yeah and so you're gonna lose your
identity
the identity as the perfect married
woman
and we're going to change that identity
for the woman who tells the truth
and the woman who is stronger than iron
you're right over the years I've just
gotten list
s of happen it's just
some braver and braver I'm getting as
far as I need to leave I need to leave
yeah but it's very very very hard to
leave by yourself it is it is that's why
I want you to talk to these three women
and
there's something surreal about saying
it out loud
even you started this call with me like
well and this is going on and he's got
some needs so bad that I I mean I feel
bad I interrupted you
I would love for you to sit down with
these three women over coffee or tea or
whatever y'all you'd like to drink and
sit down and go my husband's been
cheating on me for a decade
and now he's moved on to multiple women
in multiple cities and it ends now
and their jaws will hit the floor
and you can smile and say to me drop it
on you like that but I for sure meant to
drop it on you like that
I need your help
and there's something empowering about
it because you don't want to say it out
loud because you don't want it to be
true and I love you enough to tell you
it is true
yeah you're the this is the first that
I've actually said it I know I can hear
it on you I know I know
oh
do you trust me that there is I know I
know there's nothing easy that comes
next nothing
but you have a great picture of your mom
that hollowed-out shell
yeah that distant look
that Dad who walks in and out of that
house like he owns Planet Earth
yes yeah that's you that's the
trajectory
and that's if your husband chooses not
just a bail
or doesn't get somebody pregnant
you're right I'd call those women ASAP
like I'd call him today or shoot him a
text message and say we need to meet
tomorrow morning for breakfast we need
to talk
oh my gosh I'm sick to my guts I hate
this for you I hate this for you I hate
this for you
they thought we were gonna have some fun
in the catfishing thing and this got
real real real fast
here's the deal Janelle um hang on the
line we're gonna hook you up with that
counseling and I'll be here every step
of the way
and um you've got Jenna's contact info I
want you to reach out anytime you want
to be back on the show you want to talk
um I got you okay
a mess
somebody threw a grenade in the middle
of your home and it was not you
but what comes next is going to be
largely what you decide
not by your hand but in your lap here we
are and here we go
you didn't cause it
you're part of the cleanup crew and
you're part of the what's next crew and
I'll be here with you we'll be right
back
[Music]
hey good folks deloni here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time those become healthy habits
they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
Hollow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling Hollow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
mean meaningful spiritual life and
choose peace remember hallow is giving
you 90 days free imagine the peaceful
habits you can establish in 90 days go
to hallow.com deloney today to start
your free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hallow.com deloney for 90
days free
all right let's go about North and talk
to Bailey in Toronto what's up Bailey
okay Dr John how are you thanks for
taking my call of course I tried my best
about but it sounded terrible can you
give me one
hey there we go perfect what's up how
can I help
so this is my question
um in my relationship why do I feel like
I have to get mad for any change to
occur I feel like this speaks more about
me than him like I am not confident
enough to speak up before things
escalate why do we wait for emotions to
boil over to talk about issues things
change how do we learn to voice our
needs before things get out of control
how do we create a relationship where
both parties feel safe to be vulnerable
about their needs wants more
specifically
what happened to us I need awesome I got
170 questions let's go all right let's
do it what what tools that you need for
what
to learn to regulate my emotions okay
and how do I learn to respond instead of
react and then how can I work on my
delivery
so it's a lot it's a lot well it's a lot
but it's it's just it's two simple sides
of a coin okay
and usually um if you ever listen to the
show very much you hear me talk about
the dance that couples get into
um my guess is it's one of two things
number one
you feel so uncomfortable saying what
you need
I don't like this in bed when you do
this I need you to be home between 5 30
and 6 because I make dinner and our kids
need to go to bed I don't like it when
your mom calls and starts telling me
what to do whatever
and it's so hard for you to say those
things that you almost have to not
almost you do you have to
boil the water so hot that the steam
pushes the lid off the top that's one
that's one Avenue
the other Avenue is you constantly
constantly
tell your husband what you need what you
want what you like and he doesn't give a
crap
and the only way he will do anything is
if you run up and grab him by the ears
and shake his head real and yell real
loud
and maybe a little bit of both
so if I put those two on the table which
one feels more natural
I feel like
I have to boil over and get angry I
think it's like an attention thing
it's like I don't want to be then I
don't want to be labeled the needy wife
or girlfriend so what if what if you
switch and he'll pay attention to me
what what if you switched it it gave him
the keys to the kingdom
what like somebody told you that your
needs made you annoying
for most men that I talk to they dream
of their girlfriends or their wives
telling them what they need
so that they can love them better they
don't know how
okay but somebody told somebody told you
needs were you being a whiny like
annoying girlfriend or a whiny annoying
wife
instead of needs being a really clear
road map for how your husband can love
you really amazingly right now
for sure
so give me an example of something you
don't like to say
or when's it let me say this you called
because of something did you get really
mad and then you got frustrated with
yourself for getting so mad
well it's because I wait until I'm
frustrated about something why whether
it be like I don't know I don't know I'm
just like
what's the last time you were frustrated
um
like over the weekend but this is
I don't have enough time to walk the dog
do my exercise see my family meal prep
you know what I mean like it's just
frustrating that we don't have enough
time to do these normal things
so then hold on there and you've created
a picture all by yourself of what normal
is of what quote unquote supposed to do
well that's what I would like to get
done in it okay okay
where does that picture come from
my routine
and what's that routine keep you safe
from
that's a good question you lean on that
routine like people have sat with lean
on cocaine
because without that list you feel
untethered and that your world is going
to unspool underneath you
yes I do like productivity and
but you don't like productivity and
accomplishments for the sake of
productivity and accomplishments you
like productivity and accomplishments
because it keeps you from having to feel
why
oh my gosh I don't know
most of the time it distills all the way
down into two things either I don't like
the life I've created for myself or more
terrifyingly I don't like me
yeah I mean there's some insecurity for
sure
upstairs why are you insecure with the
guy that looked you in the eye and said
until the end of time and Beyond I do
I'm confident with his loyalty
but you're not confident with his love
why
because
he didn't stand up for me on on an
occasion we had a we had a grenade
thrown into our living room and now it
was a terrible position for any for like
a father to put a son in I can go in the
background if you want
here's what here's what's instructed so
is your father-in-law said something
awful about you and he didn't stick up
for you
away from home so it was just me and the
father-in-law and we weren't getting
along and I ended up leaving the house
um and yes like my partner never stuck
up for me so I just again I put that GPS
pin in like my body is unsafe here like
it's just hard to trust again it is even
though he's kept showing up I know I'm
just wary but that means you've you've
held you're holding on to that did he
apologize yeah I know foreign
the dance that happens
you're mad at him about something that
happened a long time ago
and
he in his mind thinks that he solved
that
yeah it would probably be shocked if he
knew that that was still lingering that
was still on his kitchen table this
morning or this weekend
and
you are confident in his loyalty but you
are not confident that he'll show up for
you or that he'll love you
and so you can see that you were walking
through your own life with no Foundation
you'd never know where the next step is
going to go because you hang on to these
things or you don't hang on to him in in
a negative way you don't deal with them
and so my question for you would be
what would it look like tonight to take
him to dinner and say I'm going to tell
you something's kind of nuts
but I'm still can find myself so mad
about that thing that happened with your
dad
and I feel like you never apologize for
me and I know it sounds bananas but I
still hang on to that
and it's hard for me to trust you
that you'll be there for me again
what if you did that
in a non-angry non-raged out non-winy
complaining way but just a
I'm freaking Bailey and I'm allowed to
have feelings and this is what they are
right now
what would that be like
I think that would be a good
conversation to have
why can't why couldn't you do that
um well we we both work for a utility
and we both work on the road so we we're
away from each other during the week and
then only see each other on weekends
but we could talk over the phone it's
not a big deal no don't do it over the
phone it's gotta be in person it's gotta
be in person
yeah but we have talked about it
um
and I I don't know again it's like the
tools I don't have the tools how do I
get over this
you know do you just do it do you just
forget about it no
you look at somebody if he reaches
across the table and grabs your hands
and says listen I'll let you down I'm so
sorry it will never happen again
and then you say thank you
I'm really grateful and then it's that
moment if you choose I'm going to choose
to believe you I'm going to choose to
trust
then from that point forward every time
that story pops into your head you
literally say out loud no not doing that
but you don't because
hell hang on a second
you replay those stories because they
make you feel powerful and they make you
feel right
and they make you feel like you are the
one done the injustice
right and then your identity over time
becomes
the worst things that ever happened to
you
and that's a miserable place to build an
identity
right
yes and so you find yourself getting mad
all the time because you don't like the
guy that you're with
and then you find yourself getting mad
all the time because you don't like the
fact that you've stayed with a guy that
you don't like
I do like them I know he is a good man
except for the fact that we want to get
over this stuff
but I don't think you do yet
or let me say it this way okay you want
to want to get over it
but it provides you something what is it
giving you what's it giving you
it's giving me nothing because it's
giving me like anger which then I yell
at him and then he shuts down and then
that's why what does anger getting this
phone call what does anger give you it
gives me the attention for like a brief
moment nothing gets to go it gives you
power oh
oh okay it gives you right
and somewhere along the way
power became a thing that made your body
the thing like made your body be able to
stand up a little bit taller
in what most relationships need is less
power and more taking a knee I love you
enough to tell you what I need
I love me to tell you enough like what I
need
and then I'm gonna fight and scratch and
Claw with my body as it tries to send
signals again oh remember last time I
remember last time nope not doing that
anymore I'm gonna lean in closer
here's going to give you a good example
like this is kind of putting my dirty
laundry out there but
um
my wife I got frustrated with something
yesterday
I caught myself
and I went outside
and by the way I was acting like a baby
also don't think this is anything great
and Noble I went outside
and I got the Armor All in a rag and I
cleaned my wife's car
and I threw away all the trash and she's
got two kids that she's traveling I mean
our two kids that she travels all over
the place with it was full of all kind I
cleaned the car and then I took it and
went and picked my son up and then we
went and got her gas
and I intentionally got the expensive
gas I don't even know why it just made
me feel like I'm giving her the best I
can so that she came in today got out in
her car and it was clean it was all arm
rolled up and
it was full of gas for the week
and by the time I got done
my little hissy fit whiny babiness was
completely gone
and it's because I took a knee
I chose service instead of power I chose
service instead of being right
and I couldn't think my way there I had
to go act I had to go do something nice
see what I'm saying
like you have to make a choice I don't
want to carry this crap anymore
but that is going to leave you feeling
exposed as exposed as the day you left
that house because your husband wouldn't
intervene with his dad
and that's the path
okay
you're like wow that sucks
no I mean I I just it's like what are
like what are practical actions in the
moment right in the moment walk away
walk away in the moment or before the
moment by the way if you get to the
moment it's too late
yeah so you all come up with it with a
hand sign
or some sort of phrase a safe word if
you will
and when you find yourself getting
enraged you say take five and you walk
away
and if you all have gone to lunch or
breakfast and on a Saturday morning when
you're actually together and you say
I'm trying to break this habit of
getting mad and every time I feel like I
need to tell you my needs I remember
this all the stuff from our past and so
I just get angry and I'm trying to stop
that so In the Heat of the Moment I'm
gonna raise my hand and just like do a
number like make a five
or I'm going to fist bump you and when I
do that don't take that as rejection
take that as me getting overwhelmed and
me taking control back over my emotions
also journaling every single day of your
life that sounds all woo-woo but what it
serves is a pressure release valve
you let it build and you let it build
you let it build and then you explode
the third thing is is a weekly every
Sunday night or Saturday night y'all
have 15 or 20 minutes to go over
calendar go over your budget and look
each other in the eye and say how can I
love you this week
and if you do those all these things up
River
then when something blows up it's not
there to come out
does that make sense
yes you're like yeah I've asked for
check-ins I've asked for check-ins
and you're not getting them I've gotten
a wave
I mean
um well
worth starting we're working on it
um the journaling I've I've gotten away
from and I want to start again
and okay uh Bailey when you listen to
this callback I want you to pay
attention to one important thing
you have completely divorced yourself
from yourself
journaling didn't just escape from you
you quit doing it
yeah yeah that's right being angry every
time you feel like you need to say
something isn't your body
um isn't like a demon landing on your
shoulder you'd get mad and you feel
powerful in that anger and you keep it
for a second
you ask your husband for something and
he just looks at you and goes I'm not
doing that and you have to live in that
guilt and in that grief that your
partner won't join you and something
that you have said is important
right
you have to get back to I I own how I
feel I own the things that I do and I'm
not going to Outsource these to other
people
and for everybody listening if you wait
until the moment to come up with an
anger exercise it's way too late
way too late anger points Us in the
direction of something we care about and
my guess Bailey is that you care so much
about this marriage and there's probably
just because I've done this a long time
I may be wrong
there's probably some stuff that is on
the table that is deeper seeded here
with you and your husband
there's conversations that you need to
have that you haven't had yet
maybe it's about work maybe it's about
Fidelity maybe it's about your romantic
relationship maybe it's about kids maybe
it's about any number of things maybe
it's about all the way back to that
situation with his family
when it came down to it you weren't
there for me maybe that's it
but your body is telling you every time
you need something he's not gonna be
there and that's where you got to
address it the anger is your body trying
to get your attention
and that's a good thing
so trying to duct tape over that is not
helpful going way Upstream so that you
get the things that your body needs like
connection like connectivity like being
on the same page like a unified purpose
like romance and intimacy all those
things Upstream so that Financial
Security so that
we need to say your needs out loud you
just say your needs out loud
but that's that's ownership of your
actions that's ownership of what comes
next it's you writing down in a journal
here's what I need
and I'm just gonna practice it and when
I feel myself getting mad stop I'm gonna
take a break because I'm getting mad
you're not doing anything I'm choosing
to get mad my body's choosing anger and
I don't know why but it is until we take
a break till I come back and then we'll
start over again and then we'll start
over again you gotta practice it
but anybody telling you on the internet
some sort of snake oil salesman telling
you this is the five steps to feel
stupid it's dumb
you're talking about reimagining your
marriage
you get as far up River as you can
[Music]
foreign
I hope you all are doing well listen
sometimes it's hard to get our brains to
turn off and I know what I'm talking
about I am the king of racing thoughts
they've kept me up at night they've got
me up early and kept me from connecting
with people I love if you find your
thoughts start to race right before bed
or during other super inconvenient times
a great way to make those racing
thoughts slow down or stop is to talk
them through and therapy gave me a place
to do that so I could get off the
negative thought treadmill learn
positive coping skills set healthy
boundaries and find some mental and
emotional peace and it can help you too
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try better help is
convenient because it's entirely online
so it's flexible and can fit into your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can even
switch therapists at any time for no
extra charge search so take a break from
Raising Thoughts with better help visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go out to
North Carolina and talk to the great and
wonderful Jackie what's up Jackie hi Dr
John thanks for having me of course
thanks for calling what's up yeah
um so my husband and I we have been
married 19 years
um High School sweethearts we have five
kids
um
but last week he revealed to me that
about 15 years ago when he was in the
military
that he had cheated on me numerous times
during his first two deployments
overseas
um
thinking back to that time I mean we're
having
issues
um and someone had actually came to me
and said that he had cheated on me
um I confronted him then about it and he
looked me dead in the eye and was like
no that's not true
um and I believed him you know because I
I thought I knew him I thought he was a
man of integrity and
um but yeah so I'm I feel like I'm at a
Crossroads I can either choose to
leave and I know what that looks like
um or I can choose to forgive him and
you know try to rebuild and that's I I
don't know what that looks like I don't
if if that's something I do choose I
don't know
how to do that
oh man
I'm sorry this happened
Sam thank you
it's like buying a house and you realize
15 years later they didn't put in a
sewer pipe or something right and you're
like right I mean that's just been going
in the backyard yeah yep yeah yeah I
feel yeah it I feel deceived
um for you know so many years that's not
a feeling that's a fact that happened
yeah right you were right and then if
you're like me I'm wondering well what
else did you not tell me exactly
anything else that you need to tell me
like this is the time just get it all
out
um that's like you're asking you're
asking a liar to tell you the truth now
right exactly yeah yeah
and of course he said no no no not at
all yeah exactly yeah
very remorseful about it um but that
doesn't you know change the fact that
I'm hurt and betrayed and I just feel
like our whole majority of our marriage
is a lie like none of it was real and
that I think is something to be careful
of because that's not true
okay
the picture you had is different
right but he did show up when your mom
got sick
okay he did come to the hospital five
times
right right right he did fill in the
blank so those things are all true and
they're all real and so burning the
whole thing to the ground is
everything's a lot it's not those things
actually happened because you were there
and you saw it you witnessed it
and
he did look you dead in the eye and say
I promise you and he lied
both are true
and so kind of like I think there's
gonna be a lot of both hands moving
forward and your temptation is going to
be to go to absolutes
there's a ton of both ands moving
forward okay
so this I I
don't have
I don't have an easy answer for you okay
um this came up a lot in 2018 and 2019.
okay when the metoo stuff happened
and people who were married had two or
three kids together or loved their
husband he was a great husband he did
all the right things
and then it was like wait a minute back
in college you
that was sexual assault right or you
raped me back like you got me all drunk
and wait a minute right and
so there was this all of a sudden this
this thing dropped to the middle of
people's homes which is who you are
right this second and my God you would
have gone to jail if you had done what
you did back then now
right
and
I
I don't know that there's another path
other than this
um
and if if anyone's got some wisdom reach
out to me on on Instagram because DM me
if you're a therapist and you've got
some a different path
but you have a choice to make and it's
very binary
I leave or I Stay
I leave I'm a single mom with five kids
and we figure out what that looks like
right I Stay
everything is new
that's it
and if I stay
I am making the choice to work as hard
as bloody hell as I can
to incorporate that not forget it you
can never forget it but to incorporate
what happened into our marriage and move
forward
because if you choose to stay and choose
to put that in that arrow in your quiver
to shoot him whenever he's late to
something or whatever he whatever then
the whole thing burns down
right yeah that's I definitely don't
want to yeah participate in that or you
know be passive aggressive towards him
or you know constantly throw it in the
face when he does something you know
wrong can I tell you what I'm hearing on
you and you can tell me if I'm crazy
okay I hear that you want to stay but
you want to want to leave
or if you know if my husband ever
cheated on me like that would be it like
there wouldn't I would walk away and now
it's I mean if he were to do this last
week like if he would have cheated on me
last week or a month ago I feel like it
would be so much easier to
walk away you'd be in the same spot
you're in right now
that's so cool to be so tough it's like
the person without kids are like if I
had kids oh you don't know right I mean
we all have these proclamations until
they happen yes yes yeah that's exactly
what it was approach and I want you to
trust Jackie not this Macho image of
Jackie that you were projecting to the
world
okay
and you're going to probably vacillate
and there's going to be days that you
really wake up and the sun is shining
and you're making breakfast and he comes
in and you lean in
and there's going to be times you pick
up a dirty shirt and you are overcome
with rage right okay right yeah there's
going to be days you want to sit down
across the table and say I want to hear
about every single girl what she looked
like what her name was where y'all were
no I don't I don't want that yeah not
yet that day will come not yet but I
promise you it'll come and there's going
to be days when you just want to say hey
that was 15 years ago we're different we
got five kids we have our home here in
the states we're moving on and
the challenge is is going to be sitting
down with a
an architect in your case a marriage
counselor
and y'all designing and building what's
going to come because your marriage as
you knew it is over
right right
and you ought to decide are we gonna
build something new and by the way he
has to be in and on it too
no he's fully committed I mean no he
thinks he is yeah everybody thinks he is
right yeah how can I trust that I don't
know you just rolled the stone away and
the dragon just came out so he thinks
he's all in he doesn't fully know yet
true what what brought this out what
brought the story
um so we we've just been like just
sharing things
um with each other just kind of like
self just like self-reflecting and you
know there we we had some really bad
times um kind of early on in our
marriage and just talking about like how
we got over that and you know um
drinking was involved on his part and
um I had shared that I had felt like
maybe he did something because I always
felt like when we were around people
there were Whispers I felt like they
were they were talking about me oh so
some of his some of his combat buddies
knew
yeah oh yeah for sure okay so
and nobody told me well I mean one
person did but they weren't close so I
you know just kind of took them at face
value and do you see that that that
that's where you're gonna have to go
because that's not just betrayal 15
years ago
yeah that is you made me the laughing
stock right oh yeah no I told him how
foolish I must have looked that's it you
know that's it yeah yeah
oh
yeah I guess yeah yeah
it's a lot and there's that other voice
it was like oh my gosh it was 15 years
ago yeah that yeah you know I was 15
years ago an idiot yeah exactly we were
we were definitely different people then
I mean that doesn't excuse the facts no
it doesn't excuse anything you know but
we were you know we were we were
different people then we've definitely
grown and matured together
um but yeah it's it's still
hurts a lot well yeah so I guess what
the best I could tell you is this
um
I would make a decision and it sounds
like I know what your decision is but I
would make a decision that I'm at least
interested in
meeting with an architect or not
okay if you're done you're done if
you're out you're right I don't hear
that on you at all no
no I don't think so I don't think so
okay you have to get let Jackie off the
hook
Jackie is not weak Jackie is not a
coward Jackie is not a wimp Jackie is
not a pushover
for staying
yeah he's very strong
yeah and that's something I've always
kind of prided myself on is you know I'm
strong I'm independent especially you
know when he was in the military and he
was gone you know I was holding things
down and you know how much infidelity
runs in in those circles and you aren't
going to be that woman here we are
yeah yeah
so in the same way that you are trying
to work through the man he was 15 years
ago
also work through this imaginary you
know pseudo Wonder Woman that you'd
created that wasn't real it's in the
past yeah this is Jackie right now
facing reality I've got five kids I love
this man I love who he has become I love
the husband he is and God I want to kill
him for what he did 15 years ago and for
the subsequent lie that that rippled
through our marriage for the last 20
years
yeah both are true
okay
and I
sometimes speaking is very hard
and I I it can be immoralist it can be a
cowardice issue whatever I tend to think
of it as a tools issue and that's
probably me being soft on people but
such it is
um
he may not know or have the ability to
sit in a room and hurt somebody like he
hurt you again
but he might be able to write it down
okay and so I would ask him
I want you to spend some time
writing out preference be handwritten
but you can type it if you'd like
anything else I need to know because you
embarrassed me
and you broke my heart yeah
and I know it's not but it feels like my
entire life is built on
a lie
and so I need you to write out for me
type it out for me what else do I need
to know
anything else any other cheating any
other office romances any other
shirtless photos you sent to somebody I
need to know every bit of it
and write it out and then write me the
letter and I'm going to read it and I'm
going to decide what's next
okay and I'm kind of 50 50 right now if
I'm super honest with you
okay I've got buddies in the military
and I've worked with enough folks in the
military that things happen overseas
then people come back and it's it's a
hard toggle because I'm not there right
right yeah um yeah no for sure no
excuses but right and the other 50 is
that's just people who cheat are people
who cheat
right yeah yeah either cheater or not
right
okay yeah it sounds like I've got um and
then if you read that letter and you say
I've made an appointment you need to be
there
and we're gonna go figure it out and I
think you tell the counselor you just
told me I found out of some pretty
um Insidious infidelity multiple women
um
over several deployments and then here
we are we need to figure out how to
build something new
and expect yourself to feel
schizophrenic
I mean I already do yeah I know I know
but but people are caught off guard by
how weirdly turned on they feel in
certain moments
okay and then how weirdly turned off
they are in certain moments okay all
right that's good to know that what I'm
feeling is normal
right now do you mind just getting weird
for a second I
and this is like a this is like a
teaching for people listening okay okay
there's a very weird oh I'll show him in
a very erotic way sometimes
okay
fair or not fair
Fair okay and then you get really pissed
at that you feel like that
and then there is also like
I will never sleep with that man again
until the end of time and then I'm gonna
add a year to that right yes and then
your over will come by this is happening
right now right and it's this toggle and
you don't know who you are anymore
yeah that's that is all true and that's
exactly yeah it's what I've been
experiencing this past week okay
and you feel super close that he told
you this deep dark secret and it was
romantic and by the way you asked for it
and also I want to kill you and bury you
in the backyard and I don't think they
would ever find your body all the same
time yes
it's jarring
okay
that's the foundation that's been
cracked
so give yourself a lot of Grace do a lot
go get a special Journal
okay
and just put the new Twin Towers you can
call it whatever you want but right okay
give yourself permission to be like oh
my gosh I haven't wanted to be with him
it's actually this bad in years and in
the very following hour I will never and
then the very following hour I've never
been this mad and Never Falling hour I
miss him so bad I wish I wish he would
just come home and hug me right now I
keep record of those things because
they're gonna they're gonna they're
important for you to process as you move
forward that's grief what you're
experiencing just that oh that would
tide away for sure yeah for sure
I hate that for you I'm sorry Jackie
yeah yeah no thank you thank you for for
talk
have you told any of your friends
all right so
um
an earlier caller unfortunately had a
similar situation but not really but
sort of
um
I think you're before you call a
counselor
after you sit with your husband ask that
letter I think you sit down with two or
three women that you really trust
and you let them know
I think I would tell them I'm not asking
for y'all's wisdom right now I just need
to say this out loud to some people I
trust that I know like that will keep it
quiet
right okay and there's something about
saying it out loud that takes it from
being surreal to this is happening to me
right now yes
is that fair that's fair and Jackie one
more thing one more thing ah okay
hahaha
I want you to put a very
dramatic in concrete and stone not even
a concrete and stone this moment that
you're feeling right now okay
you have a default setting that rolls
off to okay cool that's great that's
great that's great that's great that's
great cool cool all right whenever you
feel uncomfortable
you roll into it let's just move on
if you bury this it will come back and
Destroy no I I know that yeah
yeah I know you know it but you I'm
trying to you have to know it enough to
do something about it I know my gummy
candies will kill me man it's like Ah
that's all right that's that's a problem
for future John this is a problem for
right now Jackie okay yeah
cool
yep because I can hear you doing it to
me
no no
I love it I love it I love it I'm in
very intimate space with you right now
and I get that but I want you just to be
cautious when you people ask me like
what do you mean by awareness and
curiosity this is it right here when you
feel your body start to go okay cool all
right cool cool cool that's when you go
nope my body's trying to run we're not
going to run this time we're standing
firm
yeah so I have to get used to being
uncomfortable and that is the next
little while of your life
Fair yeah that's fair yeah I'm so sorry
this happened I'm so sorry this happened
and I'm so grateful for you being brave
because because of your bravery this
conversation is going to help a whole
bunch of people and to feel a little bit
less nuts
just crazy when these things happen just
it completely unspools people and so um
thank you for being brave I'm really
grateful for you we'll be right back
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm super
jazzed to announce my new book building
a non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order listen we all experience some
level of anxiety or stress or burnout
every day but most of us don't know how
to recognize it let alone deal with it
and here's the good news anxiety doesn't
have the last word I know this because
I've sat with thousands of you and I
know this because I've been there too if
you create a life of intentionally
living out the six daily choices I've
outlined in this book you'll be able to
better respond at whatever life throws
at you this book will help you learn
practical steps to overcome anxiety plus
when you pre-order the book now I'm
gonna give you something to help you
today that's why you'll instantly get my
newest talk smoke fire and freedom where
I break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-anxious life today for just 20 bucks
at John deloney.com
[Music]
right as we wrap up today's show it's
time for am I the problem it's me
that's not really The Melody of that but
all right Jenna let's do this Kelly's
out of town or Kelly's not here she's
not feeling well not feeling well that's
right same thing I'm gonna fill in for
her so here we go here's this one um
came from somebody who she said am I the
jerk a neighbor left a beer on my
doorstep for me to find when I came home
from work one night the neighbor already
knew I do not drink bringing it bringing
it in my house temporarily felt like it
changed the environment I decided to
give it back to them the next day before
I left for work I left it on their step
as they were not around my friend thinks
I was rude to give it back and should
have handled it differently
am I the jerk
I don't even understand that at all
Okay so
Here's my thought on this so she she
doesn't drink
the neighbor brought her a beer and put
it on her doorstep I guess I'm assuming
the neighbor knows she doesn't drink yes
she said they don't know however were
they just trying to like maybe just be
friendly like hey here's a beer in your
doorstep and maybe they forgot too just
throw it away you said that that's what
I thought too just pour it out just
think you throw it away take it the
trash can yeah but at the same time it's
not like she threw it at her neighbor's
house she just put it back on the door
yeah there's no jerk move here there's
there's mature and immature yeah no
communication yeah no one has
buddy you've just been moving a beer
right and it's two people now starting
to Gin up stories in each other's heads
exactly nobody's got time for that right
so like no I don't think anybody's a
jerk here if you smash their car with it
or threw it through the window yeah that
would be on you right
um or if they like
I don't know knew you were recovering
alcoholic and like they would be the
jerk right this just sounds like you
yeah because I don't know what their
reasoning is for not drinking I don't
know and yeah but I mean maybe the
neighbor forgot and thought they were
just doing a fun thing and put beers in
everybody's doorstep
you know that's they got different
friends than I have but yeah at the end
of the day if somebody put something on
your doorstep you don't like just throw
in the trash and move on your life
and if they say like uh
did you like the beer you say no I don't
drink you know I don't drink I threw it
away
and I mean tada
America our problems are so solvable we
can solve them all all of them
my God
we can solve them all
and that's what we're doing right here
see you soon love y'all bye
[Music]